Hey whoa yeah what up how's it going
Hayley give him for real it is certainly
Steve Oh for real and I have just viewed
your butthole that's a fine little BH
you got right there oh my god how
embarrassing kazoo okay yeah I'm the
person I know you've done more American
stuff I love your s-sure yeah my
butthole is far more blown out the
mirrors Knoxville is the one who broke
his dick so when's this Busey concert
I'm trying to thank ya you know and do
you have an extra ticket for me listen
listen look that's what I was gonna tell
you
I got VIP but it wasn't for that that's
not what I was saying I know that's what
it looks like and I was it sounded like
are you gonna give me some tickets for
doing this and then uh but that's not
why I did it you did it because you have
the utmost respect for Busey and and so
do I you know I would show him my
butthole in a flash tickets yeah you
should feel you should feel not only
better but you should feel great
today should be the best day of your
life yeah no no we're not Brucie and and
and all those people nice on your
page it says that they got no pimps no
boyfriends that's good yeah up
Empire right yeah one time I was in New
York City and I was trying to film a
stunt where I went under a bridge and
paid a hooker to piss on me I did it it
was great but I'll tell ya I had
experience negotiating with those
pimps I did not enjoy that that
was underneath the bridge in New York
City quite a while ago I mummified
myself and saran wrap is really pretty
funny of course with you I wouldn't have
to do that I know that because I seen
that pussies clean this is a Comedy
Central Comedy Central radio on Sirius
XM and you're live with big Jay oakerson
and Dan Soder these guys are funny
yeah that's true that's very true I saw
the video this is Jay I saw the keeping
score yeah you're the star of the video
lady and and you got a great you know a
real great sense of humor and you're a
good sport yeah Haley Haley if somebody
like me walks into it son you don't know
it's picture me like Jason Lisle a book
a pile of book bags in a sweat suit wow
he looks like the guy in raising Arizona
who is chasing
Randall Tex Cobb have you have you ever
had to tap out from size and dick size
no Wow Wow
clean and accommodating Posey right
that's good you're not gonna get service
and a smile like that
so how do you feel about a guy who after
he finishes wants to snuggle
oh I never ever was able to and we're
talking a real light like a lock up like
a spooning not an intertwined I don't
like that like boyfriend-girlfriend
if I'm not your girlfriend I'm not your
girlfriend I'll make you feel good I'll
put on a good show I'll give you what
you want but like all that extra I
don't you know what's the weirdest
request you've ever had from somebody
there's got to be some great ones
oh the weirdest or the weirdest is kind
of like the sick it's like sick
like this dude had called and I could
look I didn't know if he was for real or
if he was not for real he was I was
ready to send him here and damn couldn't
get him in trouble because he was
talking about coming with a
five-year-old little girl yeah I was
very real about that and the fact that
you would tell people about the I'm just
joking oh that's okay so back to
this girlfriend experience extra
does that mean no deep tongue kissing
how about like I guess kissing not cool
kissing cool I don't want to kiss
everybody but you know kissing is cool
what about just some white compliments
like those shoes are nice yeah how about
if I make a fart noise with her mouth on
your belly
inside jokes what if I want to smoke a
little bit of crack while we're on our
date would you enjoy a little bit of
crack with me okay would you would you
be comfortable with me arguing with bill
collectors while you sat next to me on a
couch okay what about other drugs what
drugs do you do coke weed if I wanna
like maybe snort some coke off your
asshole is that okay yeah do you like a
little coke in your asshole and numb it
up a little bit
she's thinking negotiation which I think
yeah right I mean you gotta meet people
halfway and I think Haley knows that
would you watch you watch me shadow box
and tell me I'm super tough and nobody
can no one can beat me that's awesome
could you tell me that you're scared and
I'm gonna say I'm scared and you're
gonna tell me there's no way I'm gonna
win the fight did you tell me that I'm
great and it's my dad's loss that he
didn't pay more attention to me would
you be willing to break down high school
football tape with me
of where I made mistakes maybe where I
could have lined up to put myself in the
play and if they go who's this girl
you say the cleanest asshole in all of
Huntsville and then spread your butt
cheeks for all friends if we were to
Applebee's would you hold the thing that
lets us know our tables ready and it
vibrates
are you currently Haley whenever we have
fun guessing can we have black Lou our
producer contact you again so we could
ask a bunch of questions with all of our
great guests like with you yeah that's
J's way of saying that you are a
star Haley answered every question Haley
you are indeed the definition of very
outgoing and fun to be with I said we're
gonna put you on hold again here thank
you so much in black Lou is gonna give
you all the info we'll make sure we get
[Music]
thank you so much
you